en este vídeo vamos a empezar con b b va
a ser un sub espacio y justo en el vídeo
anterior hablamos bastante acerca de sub
espacios y bueno este super espacio bem
va a ser el espacio vectorial generado
por un conjunto de vectores y
curiosamente también en el vídeo pasado
vimos que todo espacio vectorial
generado por un conjunto de vectores es
un sub espacio válido así que tenemos un
conjunto de n vectores y nos tomamos el
espacio vectorial generado por estos
vectores y además voy a suponer que
todos estos vectores son linealmente
independientes es decir el conjunto de
vectores b1 b2 hasta b n es linealmente
independiente y antes de dar el golpe
certero quiero recordar que significaba
que tuviéramos un espacio vectorial
generado por estos vectores y bueno
esencialmente en un espacio vectorial
generado por n vectores quiere decir que
nos vamos a tomar todos los vectores que
tienen la forma de una combinación
lineal
de estos vectores es decir no voy a
tomar a todos los vectores que se ven
como c 1 x b1 c2 x de 2 más
así hasta cn por b en donde cada seis es
un número real existen los números
reales y bueno tomándome todas las
combinaciones lineales de estos vectores
así generó el espacio vectorial generado
por estos vectores y bueno ya que
andamos recordando vamos a recordar
también que significa que estos vectores
sean linealmente independientes estos
vectores son linealmente independientes
si se uno por ver uno más c 2 x b 2 + c3
por b 3 más así está cn por b n igual a
0 tiene como única solución que ese 1 c
2 c 3 c n todos sean 0 es decir que ese
1 sea igual a c 2 y esto se iguala c3 y
así hasta cn y todos estos sean igual a
cero y todos estos sean igual a cero o
dicho de otra manera que no podemos ver
a ninguno de estos vectores como una
combinación lineal de todos los demás
ahora bien si estas dos condiciones
pasan es decir que estos vectores
generen
avn al sub espacio ven o en dado caso
cree en el espacio ven o construyan a
vemos como el que han decir y además
este conjunto de vectores son
linealmente independientes entonces
estos vectores y dejando ponerle su
nombre les voy a poner el nombre s es
decir que ese es el conjunto de los
vectores b1 b2 b3 así hasta bn y
entonces si pasan estas dos condiciones
que generen al sub espacio y además que
sean linealmente independientes voy a
decir que ese es una base de b es una
base del psuv espacio ven y viceversa si
digo que ese es una base del psuv
espacio ven entonces deben de ser
linealmente independientes y además
deben de generar ave y es que esto es
una idea bastante increíble porque
hablar de bases nos va a servir bastante
para ver todos los vídeos posteriores
pero más aún imagínate que yo tengo
este mismo conjunto de vectores pero
además le agregó otro vector y déjame
escribirlo por aquí si yo tengo este
mismo conjunto de vectores pero le
agregó otro vector déjame llamar ese
conjunto te te va a ser igual al
conjunto de vectores de b1 b2 b3 así
todos estos hasta llegar a bn y además
le voy a aumentar no se ve en bs bs va a
ser nuestro vector especial y supongamos
que bs lo podemos ver como la suma de b1
b2 bs curiosamente es la suma de b1 b2
puede ser cualquier combinación lineal
de todos los demás entonces primero
claramente tema no es linealmente
independiente porque estamos encontrando
este vector bs que es una combinación
lineal de otros dos pero más aún el
espacio vectorial generado por t va a
ser igual a b es decir que va a ser el
mismo espacio vectorial generado por
todos los demás vectores excepto de
aquí voy con todo esto bueno déjenme
escribirte aquí abajo que te no es
linealmente independiente por lo tanto t
es linealmente dependiente que no es
no es una base debe recuerda que justo
esa era una de las propiedades que
necesitábamos y bueno no es una base de
bem porque a lo que me estoy refiriendo
es que este conjunto es de n vectores es
un conjunto mínimo que genera a b tal
vez ésta no sea la definición más formal
pero bueno es mi forma de verlo mi forma
de verlo es que cuando yo me refiero a
una base de bem estoy pensando en un
conjunto mínimo de vectores es un
conjunto mínimo de vectores
y generan a ver que generan a ver que
crean a ver que construyen la vez que
generan el sub espacio el sub espacio ve
y bueno esto que acabo de decir es
bastante importante porque me estoy
refiriendo a este conjunto de vectores
que tengo aquí y este conjunto de
vectores es muy importante a comparación
de este otro conjunto de vectores que
tenía aquí donde ve ese es un vector que
además de ser una combinación lineal de
los otros dos es un vector del cual
podemos prescindir o dicho de otra
manera podemos decir que bs es un vector
redundante es decir que no nos da una
información nueva y como no nos da una
información nueva entonces solamente
estamos generando de nuevo ave este
vector es redundante y bueno esto quiere
decir que cuando yo tengo una base debe
cada uno de los vectores que constituyen
la base debe cada uno de estos vectores
es necesario para construir la base debe
no hay ninguno redundante y bueno una
vez dicho esto vamos a hacer alguna
me voy a tomar el espacio vectorial
generado por estos dos vectores ese va a
ser mi conjunto de vectores de m y voy a
poner aquí un par de vectores del vector
23 y voy a tomarme el vector am ocurre
poner el 77 0 ese es el conjunto de
vectores 2 3 y 7 ser muy bien ahora lo
primero que quiero probar lo primero que
quiero ver es si de pura casualidad
este conjunto con dos vectores generan a
r2 y si no genera r 2 cuál es el espacio
vectorial generado por estos dos
vectores pero si genera r 2 ya lo
hicimos porque sería una buena
aproximación para que fuera una base de
r 2 y bueno entonces para ver qué genera
este par de vectores lo que voy a hacer
es tomar una combinación lineal de estos
dos vectores y ver qué es lo que pasa sé
uno que va a multiplicar al vector 2 3
más 2 que va a multiplicar el vector 7 0
esto quiero que esté igual a x
x2 y x1 y x2 quiero que sean cualquier
número cualquier número que esté en los
reales y con esto obtengo este par de
ecuaciones 2 x 1 + 7 por 0 2 es igual a
x 1 y por otra parte tengo que 3 veces
se 100 x se 12 0 es igual a x2 pero de
esta segunda ecuación ya puedo despejar
a c1 c1 es igual a x2 entre 3 y bueno al
menos ya sé que dado cualquier vector x
1 x 2 puedo encontrar una manera muy
sencilla hace 1 ahora sustituyendo el
valor de ese 1 en esta primera ecuación
me queda que dos tercios de x 2 2 x x 2
/ 3 es dos tercios de x 2 + 7 x c 2 es
igual a x 1 lo único que estoy haciendo
es sustituyendo este valor de ese 1 en
la primera ecuación para ver si de
equipo despejar hace 2 y que me quedan 7
bs 2 es igual a x uno menos dos tercios
de x2 y ahora sí dividido todo entre 7
voy a encontrar por fin el valor de c 2
c 2 va a ser igual
1 entre 7 menos 2 entre 21 x 2 y fíjate
bien ya tengo dos fórmulas explícitas
para encontrarse 1 y c 2 dados cualquier
x 1 y cualquier x 2 si yo te doy
cualquier x1 y x2 en los reales es decir
te doy el vector x 1 x2 cualquiera que
sea este vector en r2
yo estoy encontrando una fórmula
explícita para encontrar a c1 y c2 que
me ayuden a darme la combinación lineal
de estos dos vectores que están en ese y
por lo tanto cualquier vector de r2 lo
puedo encontrar con estas dos fórmulas
con c 1 y con c 2 y por lo tanto estoy
diciendo que el espacio vectorial
generado por estos dos vectores por el
vector de los tres el vector 70 es igual
a r 2 a todo el plano cartesiano es
decir que este conjunto de vectores se
genera a r2 y perfecto ya tengo la
primera propiedad genera a r2 este par
de vectores genera r 2 pero esto no me
basta para decir que es una base para
decir que es una base necesito probar
también que son linealmente
independientes y para probar que son
linealmente independientes me voy a
tomar hace un nombre por el primer
vector por el vector 2 3 más de 2 por el
vector 70 y esto lo voy a ser igual al
vector 0 0 y si la única solución para
esto es obtener c1 y c2 igual a cero
entonces son linealmente independientes
y vamos a ver ya tengo una fórmula para
hacer uno y para hacer dos si yo te doy
un x1 y un x2 pero en este caso x1 vale
0 x2 vale 0 es decir que me estoy
tomando el vector 0 0 y si yo pongo en
estas fórmulas x1 igual a 0 y x2 igual a
0 obtengo que ese uno es igual a 0 entre
3 lo cual es 0 y c2 es igual a 0 entre 7
menos 2 por 0 entre 21 a lo cual es 0 y
perfecto acabo de encontrar quedado x 10
x 20 c1 y c2 son igual a 0 y por lo
tanto este conjunto de vectores también
a su linealmente independiente es el
conjunto de vectores s es linealmente
independiente y qué creés sigue
linealmente independiente y además el
espacio vectorial generado por s es
igual a r 2 entonces estoy diciendo que
ese es una base de r 2 s es una base de
r 2 y esto está perfecto porque estamos
hablando de bases en este vídeo acabo de
construirle una base r 2 ahora mi
pregunta es será esta la única base de r
2 y pues bueno para esto vamos a
tomarnos qué te parece otro conjunto de
vectores me voy a tomar a ti te va a ser
mi conjunto de vectores y me voy a tomar
el 1 0 y el 0 1
estos dos vectores de r 2 ahora mi
pregunta es
estos dos vectores serán una base de r 2
pues primero vamos a ver qué generan
estos dos vectores vamos a ver si
generan r 2 y bueno date cuenta que
cualquier lector x 1 x 2 lo podemos
encontrar de una manera muy fácil si
nosotros multiplicamos x 1 por el primer
vector más x 2 por el segundo vector
esto nos va a dar siempre el vector x 1
x 2 por lo tanto segundo sería igual a x
1 2
igual x2 y nos estamos dando cuenta que
entonces el espacio vectorial generado
por estos dos vectores es todo r2 ahora
serán estos dos vectores linealmente
independientes y bueno esto también está
muy sencillo de verlo porque si yo en
lugar de x1 y x2 pongo 0 y 0 pues la
única forma de que esto me dé 0 0 tiene
que ser que x1 sea cero y que x 12 a 0
por lo tanto estos dos vectores son
linealmente independientes y si son
linealmente independientes y generan r 2
que por cierto déjenme escribirlo aquí
estos dos vectores son linealmente
independientes ya tengo acá arriba que
generan r 2 y entonces estos dos
vectores constituyen una base de r 2
forman una base de r 2 entonces ya tengo
otra base de reduce acabo de encontrar
otra base de re 2 porque t también es
una base de r 2 y más aún r 2 bueno r 2
es un sub espacio de r 2 esto es muy
fácil de probarlo pero más que eso
r2 tiene una infinidad de bases y de
hecho cualquier sub espacio rn tiene
una infinidad de bases y bueno esto
sería muy bueno probarlo en algún vídeo
pero lo que quiero que veas es más bien
lo que quiero hacer ahorita es ponerle
un nombre muy especial a tema porque
seguramente en alguno de tus libros de
matemáticas o de física has visto estos
dos vectores y estos dos vectores se le
conocen como los vectores canónicos esta
es la base canónica o la base estándar
de r2 y a estos vectores se les pone un
nombre especial este es mi vector
y este es mi vector j mis vectores
canónicos y director canónico j y lo
padre es que cualquier factor que se te
ocurra en r2 lo podemos generar siempre
con estos dos vectores canónicos con iu
y con jota y de hecho es justo lo que
quiero que veamos en este momento si yo
me tomo cualquier vector de r2 este
vector lo puedo formar de manera única
con solamente una combinación lineal de
y de jota y bueno para esto déjenme
mover la pantalla y aquí me voy a tomar
v 2 así hasta bn vectores tales que
estos vectores
imagínate que forman una base de un sub
espacio y le voy a llamar a este nuevo
su espacio 1 es decir estos vectores son
linealmente independientes y además
generan aún es un sub espacio muy bien
ahora lo que yo quiero probarte en este
tiempo que me queda lo que yo quiero
hablarte es que imagínate que me tomo un
vector y no me voy a tomar un vector de
eeuu como este vector está en 1 lo
podemos escribir como una combinación
lineal de estos vectores que tengo aquí
porque estos vectores que tengo aquí
forman una base de 1 ahora la
combinación lineal que se forma de estos
vectores que está aquí es única y bueno
vamos a intentar demostrarlo por
contradicción imagínate que a existen y
como a existen un entonces puedo
encontrar una combinación lineal de
estos vectores que me deja así que vamos
a poner aquí la combinación lineal de
sus vectores que me va a dar este vector
a amd es igual a c uno por b 1
c 2 x b 2 más así todos 22 todos hasta
llegar a cn por bn ahora imagínate que
existe otra vamos a suponer que existe
otra combinación lineal de estos
vectores que me da también el vector a
vamos a ver a que llegamos entonces a
también lo podremos escribir de la
siguiente manera a lo podremos escribir
como de 1 vamos a suponer por b 1 más de
2 x de 2 más
así hasta llegar a de n por b n ahora si
esto es cierto qué pasa si restamos
estos 2 qué pasa si nos tomamos la resta
de estos dos vectores a menos am bueno a
menos a me va a dar el vector 0 me voy a
tomar la diferencia de estos dos y el
vector 0 va a ser igual a quién pues
factor hizo a b1 b2 y así hasta bn me va
a quedar esto escrito de una manera
mucho más fácil como se uno menos de uno
por b uno y después a esto le voy a
sumarse todos menos de 2 x b 2 y así más
o no estamos llegando a la parte del
pizarrón que siempre tengo problemas
esta parte fíjate fíjate como aquí tengo
y no puedo escribir bien entonces aquí
medio borro y esto es un caos nunca
puedo escribir bien en esta esquina del
pizarrón y no he podido arreglar este
problema entonces mira mejor no nos
hagamos bolas me voy a mover un poco
para acá y voy a escribir otra vez lo
mismo a menos a es cero el vector cero y
entonces me queda así factor y sobre uno
como c1 c1 por b uno más de dos por b 2
que multiplica el vector de 2 y así
hasta llegar a cnn que multiplica el
vector bn pero date cuenta como sabemos
que estos vectores son linealmente
independientes la única forma porque
recuerda que están en una base de un
entonces todos estos son linealmente
independientes la única forma de que una
combinación lineal de estos vectores me
dé el vector 0 es que cada una de las
constantes que está al lado de los
vectores sea igual a cero esto quiere
decir que cada una de estas constantes
tiene que ser igual a cero estar aquí
tiene que ser igual a cero esta de aquí
está atacada también tiene que ser igual
a cero todas éstas tienen que ser igual
a cero porque es mi única solución
una combinación lineal de estos vectores
y que me dé igual a cero recuerda que
todo esto porque son linealmente
independientes y bueno si todos estos
son igual a cero esto quiere decir que
si uno tiene que ser igual a de uno de
dos tiene que ser igual a de dos etc
ctera fíjate lo que llegamos esto quiere
decir que ese uno de aquí si sea uno
menos de uno es igual a cero según no
tiene que ser igual a de 1 c 2 tiene que
ser igual a de 2 y así hasta llegar a
que se tiene que ser igual adn y por lo
tanto lo que estaba haciendo es escribir
a amd de dos maneras iguales porque sea
uno es igual a de 112 es igual a de 2 y
así todos los demás por lo tanto fíjate
bien había supuesto que habría dos
formas de escribir al vector a y
encuentre que solamente hay una forma de
escribir al vector a lo que quiere decir
que la forma de escribir a este vector a
es única
cualquier vector que esté en el sub
espacio solamente lo podemos escribir de
una manera única como una combinación
lineal de esos vectores linealmente
independientes y bueno todo esto me
lleva a una última pregunta si yo le
agrego un vector a este conjunto que
tengo aquí este conjunto será una paz
r2 y la respuesta es que no porque a
este vector lo podemos encontrar como
una combinación ideal de estos dos
porque habíamos visto que estos dos eran
una base de r2 y por lo tanto generaban
todo r2 y si generan todo el rededor
entonces generará el vector 10 entonces
podemos encontrar una combinación lineal
de estos dos vectores que me den 10 y
entonces estoy diciendo que este vector
es redundante este vector cuando se lo
agrego a este conjunto me da un conjunto
linealmente dependiente y recuerda que
no queremos conjuntos linealmente
dependientes cuando hablamos de bases no
olvides que podemos ver una base como el
conjunto mínimo de vectores que generan
bueno en este caso a r2 el conjunto de
vectores más eficientes que generen a r2